I read a lot of tributes to Muhammad Ali
and you know realizing what Ali meant to
Kareem abdul-jabbar and in Time magazine
if you get a chance I thought that it
was just eloquently written and probably
joyful and painful at the same time for
Kareem but he really paid tribute to
Muhammad Ali and got to spend time with
him I thought it was really well done
and Kareem kind enough to join us
good morning Kareem thanks for joining
us no problem Darren are you doing I'm
doing okay I
I'll drag you in - best team of all time
in Showtime versus Golden State but let
me ask you about Muhammad Ali what was
it that made you to click you know it
started I started admiring him when I
was in high school oh really when I was
still in grade school the 1960 Olympics
I thought he was really neat and then
from that point on his professional
career really made me a fan I really
enjoyed the way we go to the his
opponents camps and taunt them and
harass them and get them all angry and
crazy he's already getting into their
head than any got into the ring and
embarrass them he was a an incredible
athlete and then the stances that he
took with regard to human rights and
civil rights it was a very very
tumultuous time in terms of civil rights
the final a couple of years of the civil
rights movement and he had a lot to
think that was very accurate and to the
point and he made us all proud you
embraced some of ali politically but not
the bravado was there any part of you
that said you know maybe i could be this
or what i like to be that could I be
that braggadocious or charismatic or
however you want to you know kind of
capture Ali was there any thought of
that well you know there's a certain
certain Kingdom that you inherit when
you're the world heavyweight boxing
champion and then the you know I I never
aspired to be that I didn't think I
could be that
what he had to say about the sticking up
for our human and political rights was
right on the money and I totally agreed
with it and I had a lot of respect for
him because of that did you ever get in
the ring with him
no no no well today I wanted to just
wanted to box Albie he was I guess he
was dreaming or you know it somewhere
deluding himself because he could fight
oh hey I didn't I
i I saw him as my friend and my brother
I didn't want to fight it mine
I think I'd let him do that I think in
basketball you know talking to Kareem
abdul-jabbar joining us we were
discussing this well it's actually
brought up by draymond Green and klay
Thompson where clay said yeah we would
be better than the Showtime Lakers and
of course his dad played on that team so
we've been discussing it and in a few
use today's rules you know today's style
the use of the three how do you think
and can you remove yourself as an
analyst though instead of a player on
that Showtime Laker team and look at
this objectively how would how would
that game play out oh you really have to
go out and play the game with the
players to find out what is what I think
the Showtime team that guys on that team
who could could be friend along the
perimeter Oh guys don't go to college
you know they don't learn how to play
defense away from the basket only it's
an offensive game though they want to
see more scoring so they eliminated hand
checking so now you can't it's very hard
to talk people away from the basket so I
think that that difference in the way
that the game is played really has
changed the dynamic and there's really
no way to compare them they're very
talented team and they would be a great
team in any era but if they played in
our suppose suppose they played in an
era where there was no 3-point shot do
they think they would win at that point
that's an interesting question they will
when without a three-point shot and I
think that that that weapon is you know
what separates them from all these teams
now but if we're playing rules in the
80s or the 90s then I like those teams I
don't I don't like Golden State I think
the the style the physicality would be
completely different and I think that
would be you know work against the
Warriors yeah and especially the fact
that they don't have any size you know
they play this you know or they call it
small ball size really matters on the
court even in an error like now with
with small ball if you have somebody who
can score inside that creates serious
problems for the defense I imagine fact
was playing against the golden sphere I
don't think how think they could do
anything with him yeah we haven't even
factored in Shaq and Kobes Lakers
against Golden State
you would take them over them as well I
think that they would it would be
competitive and Kobe could shoot the
long range jumper with a lot of accuracy
and efficiency so that would that would
change it I think and you can find out
unless you put the team's on board and
let him go at it we just argue about
this this is why they have how different
would your game be today with the style
if you were coming out of college now
what would you be shooting threes um I
might have to given the style of play
that that the coach dictated but I was
very effective in the paint
what I shot something like 56% life plan
that's pretty good you know but I see
porzingis at seven for shooting threes
you know Nowitzki was the excellent
three-point shooter at 17 or so you know
seven foot guys can shoot the ball but
it you know it really depends on the
style that would work
for whatever the team was that's such a
dealer would I have you with one
three-pointer in your career that's it
you ready you're re I remember yes I
miss with from the short you know right
there in the corner there I I ran out
into the corner to get a rebound nobody
came to gardening so I step back I said
what the hell else I'll shoot this
reporter I made it
that was good Kareem you look like a
ladder unfolding when you're taking that
shot from the corner here or you gotta
see but it went in real nice we're down
thanks for joining us on short notice
and I really really enjoyed the time
magazine comments about Muhammad Ali you
know what it's I know what he meant to
you and it certainly came across so
thank you
Thank You Kareem you're welcome Dan take
care that's Kareem abdul-jabbar Lakers
NBA Hall of Famer the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience